Holly Williams has reported extensively
throughout the Middle East she joins us
from Erbil Iraq Holly what does the
death of Soleimani mean for the tensions
between the u.s. and Iran and in the
region as a whole
the Pentagon says its drone strike
targeting Major General Qasem Soleimani
was aimed at deterring future attacks by
Iran it's part of president Trump's
so-called maximum pressure campaign
against the Iranians but there are fears
that the killing of sulamani a revered
figure in Iran and some other places in
the Middle East could see simmering
tensions between the u.s. and Iran turn
explosive the loss of Qasem Soleimani is
a heavy blow to Iran he was a war hero
the commander of Iran's feared goods
force responsible for secretive foreign
operations he wasn't well known in the
United States but he was one of the most
powerful figures in the Middle East
sometimes even touted as a possible
future leader of Iran for America though
general Soleimani
was a problem in April last year the
u.s. designated that could force a
foreign terrorist organisation we're
sending a clear signal a clear message
to Iran's leaders including Qasem
Soleimani and his band of thugs that the
United States is bringing all pressure
to bear to stop the regime's outlaw
behavior the Pentagon says sulamani was
responsible for the deaths of hundreds
of American and coalition servicemembers
and also approved the attack on the US
Embassy in Baghdad this week but even
many of sulemani x' enemies admitted he
was a military genius he spearheaded
Iran's involvement in the Syrian civil
war helping to shore up the Syrian
regime's grip on power and in Iraq
ironically he and his forces were on the
same side as the u.s. fighting against
Isis by killing Qasem Soleimani the US
has stripped Iran of an inspirational
military leader but it's also further
inflamed dangerously high tensions Iran
has already vowed to take quote harsh
revenge Holly Williams CBS News
bill Iraq
you